and welcome to the sas base programmer
certification course offered by simply
learn
the objectives of this domain will be
discussed in the following screen
completing this domain you will be able
to
define sas and its features
list down sas functions and its
consumers
describe the sas exam
understand the benefits of sas
certification for professionals
certification for employers
we will start our discussion with
understanding sas and its features in
the next screen
statistical analytical service commonly
known as sas is a software suite
developed by the sas institute for data
storage and analytics
it is the largest market share holder
for advanced analytics
the primary features of sas are
providing tools for performing advanced
analytics like statistical and
mathematical analysis on stored data
enabling business intelligence to reveal
hidden data patterns
handling giant data records for storing
managing and retrieving purposes
performing predictive analysis to
forecast future outcomes for any
structured business
in the next screen we will discuss the
major domains and consumers of sas
the as software suite comprises core
modules inbuilt functions
these enable users to capture data from
different kinds of sources
sas enables the cleansing and
classifying of data in a global standard
format and storing it in predefined
layouts
sas provides many functionalities which
support users to manage data in the form
of huge data records it provides an easy
and quick approach to retrieve the data
stored in the desired format
sas also provides many inbuilt functions
which empower users to perform
statistical and mathematical analysis on
stored data
sas offers many in-house functions to
generate business reports in different
formats
being a leading software suite used for
advanced analytics and data management
sas is used in different sectors
it is widely used in the financial
sector for example in retail banking
equity insurance investment banking and
many more
sas is also widely used in the field of
medicine for analyzing the results of
clinical trials
government institutes and defense units
use sas primarily to capture and store
classified records
sas is also used in business sectors
like automotive and communication where
huge sets of records are generated and
handled on a daily basis
in the next screen we will talk about
the examination and pass criteria for
sas based certification
the as base programmer certification
exam comprises 64 multiple choice
questions
you need to score 70 marks to clear the
examination
there is no negative marking and all
questions hold the same weight
the duration of the examination is 110
minutes
you will receive an immediate pass fail
score on completing the exam at your
testing facility
the score report will display the
percentage of items in each section that
you answered correctly for your exam
please note that these scores are
calculated on a per second basis and
cannot be used in determining your total
score they are provided to you for
descriptive purposes only
if you pass your exam and meet all the
requirements for this credential you
will receive an email from sas with
instructions providing access to your
certificate and logo through the
certification records management system
this email will be sent to the email
address you provided to pearson vue
while registering for the exam
some individual firewalls may send this
email to your junk folder
please wait for at least one week from
your exam date to receive your email
once within the certification records
management system you can access your
certificate on the left navigation bar
under printable documents
to print your certificate disable your
pop-up blocker before clicking the print
now button
click print now and your certificate
will open in a new window from which you
can download and or print it
in the next screen we will discuss the
process of registering for the exam
registration for the sas base
certification exam can be done with
pearson vue which is the education
partner of sas and responsible for
conducting the examination worldwide
exam registration can be done online or
by phone only
no registration can be done within a
test facility
a minimum of 24 hours is required by
returning candidates to register
first-time candidates require additional
time as listed
to register yourself please visit
www.pearsonview.com
forward slash sas
the next screen will talk about the
benefits of sas based certification for
professionals
the es base certification program has
been designed to recognize sas software
users who can demonstrate an in-depth
understanding of the sas software
sas certifications are developed
according to defined international
standards
and based on survey results and feedback
from users
the certification program provides you a
means to validate your sas software
skills and earn industry recognition for
your knowledge
with a professional certification from
sas you will set yourself apart from the
competition today by earning the only
globally recognized credential endorsed
by sas
invest in yourself today and reap the
benefits tomorrow
in the next screen we will talk about
the benefits of sas based certification
for employers
candidate with sas credentials means
you're getting a qualified professional
with proven proficiency in sas not to
mention that an sas certification can
also increase individual productivity
levels
those who possess a credential from sas
have gone a step above the competition
to validate their sas expertise
to attract the most qualified sas
candidates consider adding sas global
certification as preferred or required
criteria on your job postings
this certification also satisfies
certification mandate requirements of
service providers or subcontractors
the sas certification serves as a
reliable benchmark for assessing your
staff internally and also provides
excellent return on your training
investment
industry research has proven that
individual and work group productivity
increases when companies employ
certified staff
regardless of whether you are looking to
attract the most qualified sas
professionals or you already employ sas
experts on your staff the sas global
certification program can provide you
with the means to take your company and
staff beyond your competition
with a professional certification from
sas your company can reap the benefits
of a more productive and efficient
workforce
let's started with the first module of
this course